>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Nick Brown: Hi there,
my name is Nicholas Brown
and I'm a music specialist
with the Library of Congress.
It's my great pleasure to
introduce you to Thomas Wilkins
who is the music director
of the Omaha Symphony
and principal conductor of
the Hollywood Bowl Orchestra.
Thank you [inaudible]
for being here.
>> Thomas Wilkins: No problem.
>> Nick Brown: We are here today
commemorating the Shift Festival
of American Orchestras.
Could you tell us a bit about that
and your involvement
in the festival?
>> Thomas Wilkins: I was just
asked to serve on a panel
to discuss really one of
the things that Shift is all
about is redefining or shifting
if you will, the orchestra's role
in the communities that they serve.
And with the hopes that in each
case specific to the community
that they're in that it would
extend beyond just playing concerts.
And the orchestras that I have
been involved in, involved with,
and even now, we have
always been about that.
And so they thought perhaps I
was a good person to come in
and make up some answers.
>> Nick Brown: Great.
So the festival is being
co-presented by the Kennedy Center
and also the Washington Arts
and the Library was a partner
today for the symposium.
What is your impression of these,
that your principal presenters
at the festival and the
impact that they're having
with changing the narrative
about orchestras in this country?
>> Thomas Wilkins: I think the fact
that they actually are big voices
in the industry is really important.
You know, they're, in
some parts of a country
where orchestras are
small, and they have quote
on quote the services, the burn.
By that what I mean is they
have plenty of musician time
that they can do things
more creatively sometimes
in a larger organization,
larger organizations
with major orchestras really haven't
had to do those things before.
So now that we are all
figuring out that no one needs
to be left behind regardless of
what size setting that you're from,
I think it's really important
that the major players are also the
ones waiving the banners as well.
>> Nick Brown: Can you
tell us a little bit
about what you're doing specifically
in Omaha and with Hollywood Bowl
in terms of engaging new audiences
and perhaps changing the public's
perception about orchestra music?
>> Thomas Wilkins: For me it
starts with, from the basic premise
that music is life
altering and life affirming.
You know as I said to the
group earlier I was a kid born
to a single mother on welfare in a
housing project, no predisposition
to classical music whatsoever.
So that when I heard the
orchestra for the first time
at eight years old, that
was what I wanted to do.
I didn't have words to describe
how impacted I was but it meant
that all the critical life choice
questions that kids are faced
with today were answered
for me by default
because I had fallen
in love with music.
Do I go to college?
What's the nature of my friends?
Where do I find myself when
there's no adult supervision?
All of those questions were
answered because of music.
So if I believe and incidentally
that that says more about the power
of music than it does about me.
So if I believe that, then
that gift of the power
of music should be
handed to as many people
in as many possible ways
as we can come up with.
And so we've always done, we've
always had, especially in a place
like Omaha, community
partners that range anywhere
from the Omaha Housing Authority
to Girls Inc to University
of Nebraska Medical Center to
hospice care and we don't walk
with a program that says, here we're
from the government,
we're here to help.
We want to know what your needs are.
And in some of those cases
it's just about access
to a place that's different
from the place
that they spend more of their time.
And that place for us happens
to be the concert hall.
And low and behold, in that
place they get the gift of music,
a world that they didn't think had
any relation to them whatsoever.
So those are the kinds of things
that we do in Omaha and of course
at the Hollywood Bowl we are very
much committed to our YOLA program,
Youth Orchestra of Los Angeles, and
now we've been doing it for so long
that we've actually seen
kids graduate and they're off
to college and doing great things.
So it's, that's a neat experience.
>> Nick Brown: Wonderful.
So in those projects
that you're working on,
do you see that they're now
different or new opportunities
for youth to get involved with
classical music as opposed
to when you were growing up?
Or is it just new packaging for
the same types of engagement?
>> Thomas Wilkins:
That's a good question.
I, well, the problem with,
the problem I didn't have
when I was growing up was
I didn't have the challenge
of their being too
many options for me.
None of us kids did, you know?
And nowadays a lot of
things have happened
that has almost exacerbated the
problem of trying to get kids
to music, one of which seems to
be preparing them for college.
You know, there are all of
these other kinds of things.
I'm really glad that the folks
who came up with the idea
of stem [assumed], I'm starting
to believe that it really needs
to be steam, that there needs
to be an arts component.
But, so I didn't have all of
those obstacles as they were,
so I had plenty of time for music.
I think, and it's, beyond obstacles
in the 21st century
it's just believing
that this music has some
application to your life.
And I've always been
about, if a kid comes to one
of my childrens' concerts
for example,
there's a couple things
that I want them to see.
I want them to see that the
orchestra is probably one
of the best representations
of a community that exists
in our society, all different
instruments, all different voices,
all different sizes, all different
levels of power and strength,
and weakness, and yet they
figure out a way to work together
so that this incredible, powerful,
beautiful product happens.
You know that the diverse group
of individuals working
together for a common good.
So I want them to see that first
and that their families can work the
same way as an orchestra can work
and their classrooms
can work the same
or their neighborhoods can work
the same way as an orchestra does.
The other thing that I
want them to understand is
that this music has
a direct relationship
to their everyday lives.
And so if I do a program
that's about Meter
and Paulson [assumed] music,
it's really about perseverance.
If I do a program that's
built around the idea
of orchestration, it's
about teamwork.
So those kinds of things happen.
And then I want them to
understand that this orchestra
on stage is theirs, that
this room is theirs.
They are welcome at any time.
In fact I make a habit
now of even in Omaha
at subscription concerts I
am seeing young children.
Right? And if they're
sitting in the first row,
they get a fist bump
from me on the way out.
You know, I give them
some wow goofy eye,
because they though they were coming
to one of these [inaudible] and all
of the sudden the conductor's
fist bumping them at a concert?
Where's the decorum in that?
Well I don't care where it is,
I want them to feel welcome.
>> Nick Brown: Well
it's very refreshing.
I'm appreciative as a concert goer
and musician myself of that attitude
because I go in to concerts and I
experience people getting chastised
because they're sharing with their
friend how much they enjoy it.
And of course there are rules
that should be respected
like not interrupting your
neighbor and that kind of business
but breaking that wall and making it
a collaborative experience I think
is such a huge part of it.
So thank you for that.
>> Thomas Wilkins: I
actually, one time, we did,
I did a set of it was a long
sweep of like 12 movements.
It could have been [foreign name]
but the piece is not
coming to mind just yet.
And I explained to the audience
before that there were 12 movements.
And the panic on their faces.
But I said they were short, and in
some instances they were really,
really short, and so we get to
the end of the first movement
in the concert and I turn to
the audience and I said, one!
And then that was all
that was required.
It was just break the ice
and now let's have some fun.
>> Nick Brown: So in your
own growing up with music,
you said when you were
eight years old was
when you first experienced an
orchestra, was that the moment
where you said I want to
be a conductor or just
that I want to be in music?
>> Thomas Wilkins: Isn't that funny?
That's the moment I said that
I want to be a conductor.
There was something about this man,
Russell Stanger [assumed]
was his name,
this was the Norfolk
Symphony Orchestra,
now it's the Virginia
Symphony, Joanne's [inaudible],
there was something about
the sound first of all,
I had never heard an
orchestra before.
But then maybe it was his movements
or whatever his exuberance,
whatever it was, there was
something about him that said to me,
that's the fun spot down there.
That's the spot that's
closest to all of that sound.
It's not the guy with the long
blonde hair playing the snare drum.
Although that looks pretty cool.
But this guy was just you know,
all over the place with this music.
And I like now to in
McDonald's the restaurant a lot
of McDonald's play lands
they would have those pits
with all plastic colored
balls and nets around it.
And my kids would love to go in
there and get under them and dive
and hide and I said for me
that's what sound is like.
That's what it's like being on the
podium is like being on one of those
and you're just surrounded
by sound and so
that was the thing
that got me right away.
>> Nick Brown: So how did you get
from that eight year old person
with a vision and sort of idea
of the future for themselves
to being a professional conductor?
>> Thomas Wilkins: At the very
beginning, and when I talk
to grown ups about how we relate
to children, one of the things
that I make note of with them is
that when I came home and said
in my neighborhood, in the hood,
that I wanted to be a conductor,
no one ever looked at
me and said no dude.
Young black boys don't
grow up to be conductors.
Nobody ever said that to me.
In fact, you know a
lot of times I got oh,
you're going to be the first
black Leonard Bernstein.
>> Nick Brown: Nice.
>> Thomas Wilkins: You
know, I was showed,
but that tells you
something Bernstein's impact,
that even in that neighborhood
people knew that name.
And so we have to be careful
what words we use when we talk
to children about their dreams and
about their goals in their lives
and no one clipped
my wings as it were.
So that was the first
thing that happened.
But then it, the very next year was
fourth grade and that was the year
that could start to play
an instrument, and so,
but everyone had to start on violin.
>> Nick Brown: Oh, really?
>> Thomas Wilkins: And
this was pre-desegretation.
And what I learned later as a grown
up, talk about fortuitousness,
I made that word up, but I went back
to visit my elementary
school principal
as a grown up, she's
now an old lady.
And she recounted the story of how
she, and she was a little lady,
you know like this, Miss Robertson,
and she went down to the school
board and she said you're going
to put strings in those
white school,
you're going to put
them in my school!
>> Nick Brown: Wow.
>> Thomas Wilkins: And they
just could not say no to her.
And had she not done that,
that violin wouldn't
have been there for me.
>> Nick Brown: That's amazing.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Yes!
So that was fourth grade and then
we could switch in fifth grade
and I switched to cello, that sort
of became my principle instrument.
And then in seventh grade, so I
played cello in the orchestra.
Seventh grade I wanted
to get a band uniform
because I thought the band uniforms
looked cool, the girls are attracted
to the band uniforms,
I've got to figure
out a way how to get a band uniform.
So during the school year I
taught myself trumpet fingerings.
So that I could go to summer
band camp and then sort
of be already be prepared and
so I went to summer band camp.
And the band director at one point
said you know if you switched
to tuba I'll let you
keep one at your house.
>> Nick Brown: Oh!
>> Thomas Wilkins: Bam!
Done!
>> Nick Brown: Were
you tall back then?
>> Thomas Wilkins: I guess so,
but the fact that I could
have an instrument in my home,
it must [inaudible] of all my
neighbors probably, you know,
there I was with my tubas.
And I played cello in the
orchestra, tuba in the band.
And also what had happened
in that seventh grade year,
was my string orchestra teacher
asked who wanted to try to conduct.
And I raised my hand of course
and I got up and I remember I was
in three four time and
three four is an art
so there's an extra motion there
that you don't know what to do with.
So I couldn't get right, and I
said that's alright I don't want
to do it.
And he goes no, no, no.
And he grabbed my hand and he
showed me and then he's like oh.
So that was my first
conductor experience.
I mean, outside of
when I was really small
and I would take my army
soldiers, plastic army soldiers,
and set them up like an orchestra
and conduct them in my bedroom.
>> Nick Brown: Oh really?
>> Thomas Wilkins: I
used to tell people
that my first conducting job
was as as a military band.
>> Nick Brown: Awesome.
Cool.
>> Thomas Wilkins: But you know,
then I ultimately chose my
undergraduate school based
on the ability to have
opportunity to conduct
that was [inaudible] territory.
I had gone, I had played every
summer I got to go to band camp
in Williamsburg playing tuba
and orchestra camp later
in the summer playing cello.
Well, I wanted to go to
orchestra camp playing tuba
so I could be the only person
playing the instrument.
So sure enough summer of my junior
year I got to go playing tuba.
And I met the tuba teacher
at Shenandoah Conservatory,
Fred Marzan [assumed] and he said,
you know if you come to Shenandoah
as a tuba major instead of cello
I'll let you be the student
conductor of my brass choir.
Done! And so it was kind of
a neat little ride there.
And then it was a school
small enough
that all the ensembles
had student conductors.
So every year I was a student
conductor of some ensemeble.
And actually got to do
a conducting recital
which no one had ever done before
so it was a really neat opportunity.
>> Nick Brown: Excellent.
Growing up and kind of through
your undergraduate period,
were they any specific pieces
that really clicked for you
or specific composers who made you
realize you were doing what you were
meant to do?
>> Thomas Wilkins: Yes.
Oh. One in particular was the hymn
that's in Jupiter, that's embedded
in Gustav Holst's Jupiter, you know
that beautiful hymn that's
just sort of stuck there.
That always transformed me,
transported me to another place.
The same thing with that same
kind of music in Gershwin Rhapsody
and blue for example, it always
sent me some place really special.
And then the slow section
of the last movement
of Moller's First Symphony.
You know, Beethoven said that
music is the one incorporeal,
intangible entrance into the
higher world of knowledge,
which understands man kind but
which man kind can not understand.
He's basically saying it knows
us though we know it not.
To extend that out I always
say that we spend our lives
as artists working on that
the substance of music
so that we can try to get
to the essence of music,
but we will never be able to put the
essence of music really into words.
You know? It's not enough
to say forte means strong,
forte means confident.
It still won't get you to
what, to one of those moments.
And so those were moments and
then they remain moments for me.
And in many instances they're
worshipful moments for me.
It is my favorite time to
worship is when I'm conducting.
So it's, yes, there have
always been places like that.
And when I come back to
them now as a grown up,
they have an extra meaning
because they are a part
of my aesthetic history as
much as they are just you know,
a piece that I'm working on.
>> Nick Brown: Do you ever associate
those or other pieces with sort
of milestone life events?
>> Thomas Wilkins: There
are moments like that,
I think for example the first time
I heard the opera Dido Aeneas.
I sat in the library and
New England Conservatory,
you know what library
I'm talking about.
And I wept like a baby.
>> Nick Brown: Oh wow!
>> Thomas Wilkins: I had the
head phones on and I'm just.
So I know exactly where I
was at that moment you know
and there are other
places like that.
In fact there was a moment
during the, doing the planets,
the Venus Movement by
the way is another one
of those exquisite moments for me.
But during that Jupiter, during
that hymn in that Jupiter, I was,
I didn't do it on purpose but, and
I was guest conducting somewhere
and my wife and my father
in law were sitting
together in the audience.
And during that moment when it got
to its grandest place I just
let go of the orchestra.
I didn't wave my arms.
I just stayed in that
position and I think I was,
what I was saying is look at how
much bigger than we are this is.
And there was no movement that
was, that seemed to be necessary.
And they got it!
>> Nick Brown: Wow!
>> Thomas Wilkins: And my father in
law said look at what he's doing.
And my wife said oh he's gone.
She told me that later.
She's like he's gone.
>> Nick Brown: Very cool.
>> Thomas Wilkins: And there,
engima, the nimrod variations,
I remember being at a
conducting camp which sounds
like the biggest nerd
festival you can ever imagine.
And it was, I wasn't conducting at
the time, but it was being played
in the room and I thought to myself,
I was already married by then,
and I thought to myself,
that describes how much I
love my wife right there.
And I told her that later.
So whenever I'm in that music
I think about that moment
that I just made that
sort of discovery.
You know, at summer
music camp for grown ups.
>> Nick Brown: What was
her response to that?
>> Thomas Wilkins: Oh it
got me some major points.
>> Nick Brown: Oh great.
Did she ever request it on the
CD player or something like that?
No? Or did you surprise it?
>> Thomas Wilkins: No, she doesn't
but often I will share music
with her if I'm some place else
that speaks of our relationship.
If it touches me in a certain
way I will send her a link
to it and you know.
>> Nick Brown: Neat.
Yes.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Romantic.
>> Nick Brown: Wonderful.
So after you did grad school,
what was the path from there?
Were you an assistant?
Did you do festivals?
>> Thomas Wilkins: It's interesting.
I didn't have, you know
there is no rhyme or reason,
there's no prescribed
route in this country.
You know, you don't, your not a
repetiteur one point and then all
of the sudden you're,
you get your chance.
My first job out of graduate school
was at a small college in Chicago,
North Park College is now North Park
University, small Christian college.
Which is, believe it or
not where I met my wife.
And it was, it was a
liberal arts college.
You know? I think, first
of all there was only eight
people on the music faculty.
So it meant that I did a
lot of stuff, you know,
taught orchestration, I taught
sophomore theory one year,
I taught conduct, all three levels
of conducting, brass methods,
string methods because
I played both.
One year I taught percussion methods
because I was the youngest person
on the faculty and therefore
the person most likely
to have remembered it from college.
It was pretty funny.
But when I called my teacher back
in New England said oh
my gosh you're not going
to believe what they have
me doing for $15,000 a year.
He said what are you talking about?
That's a great job for you!
You're not going to always
be a friend or your fellow,
you need to learn how to
teach people to play better.
You know, and he was right.
So it was, it wasn't a
crummy job, it was just not,
it wasn't the New England
Conservatory,
where I had just graduated from.
And that was a whole different
level of student musicians.
But it was good for me to be there.
And I've always, not always
believed but certainly much
of my life I believe that you
bloom where you're planted.
And you try to grow
wherever you are,
contribute whatever you
can while you're there.
But to not let a day go by
where you don't learn something.
And I had always said that, excuse
me, that more than anything I wanted
to be prepared for the next thing.
So, you know, that job led
to another university job
at the University of Tennessee in
Chattanooga and I was only there
for two years because I taken
a Richmond Symphony audition.
The assistant conductor audition.
And I made finals and
then didn't hear anything.
And it just so happened that Marian
Alsip is a very good friend of mine
and she had also taken the audition.
And so after a while I called
Marian and I said Marian,
I haven't heard a thing
from Richmond, have you?
She goes, yes, they hired me.
I went oh!
Congratulations!
We still crack up about that.
And then her career
took off and she left.
She was leaving, preparing to
leave, and so they called me
and said you know, we don't
want to do another audition,
quite frankly you were
our second choice anyway,
if you want the job,
the job is yours.
>> Nick Brown: Wow.
>> Thomas Wilkins: So sure enough
I got that job and I was there
for I don't know how long,
five, six, seven years maybe.
And then I got a job with
the Florida Orchestra
as the resident conductor there.
And that was great.
And the best thing about that
job was that believe it or not,
was that the music director
was hardly ever there.
So I got to learn how to do a lot of
music director stuff, meet people,
engage people, go on, ask
for you know for funding.
I became really an integral part
of the community getting on boards
and involved in the life
of the community outside
of the concert hall.
And that was really the formative
years for me of learning how
to be a conductor was really
learning how to be an artist
in a community and
how important it was.
You know, when I left Florida
to go to Detroit, I guess that's
where we went next, I was
just walking down the street
and a lady stops at a red light.
Gets out of her car.
And comes and hugs me and goes
oh I'm going to miss you so much.
I don't know who that lady was.
>> Nick Brown: Wow.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Yes, it
was a really neat thing.
And it wasn't because I'm the
greatest conductor they have ever
seen but it was because they
had someone who really cared
about their lives and their
childrens' lives and wanted
to be partners with them in the
raising of their children and wanted
to be partners with them
in enhancing the quality
of life in their community.
That's what they saw,
that's what they loved more
than anything else I think.
>> Nick Brown: So how do you try
to teach that kind of set of values
to younger conducting colleagues
or students or even you know,
relatives who are young
growing up or your kids as well?
Because I think a lot of those
things that conductors deal
with are life skills that
maybe not everyone realizes.
So you can go be a leader in your
community whether you're a conductor
or you're a business
person or whatever else.
But yes, I'd love to
just hear your thoughts.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Well you know
people don't follow great leaders
because they're necessarily
great people.
Great leaders present visions of
things that are larger than us
that we want to be a part of.
And I think first and foremost
you have to live your life
in a way that's reverent.
So that no one ever
gets, no one ever thinks
that you think you are more
important than the music.
And I think part of the success
that I've had as a conductor is
that when I'm in front of an
orchestra they all understand
that together we are fortunate
first of all to be in this room,
and that we could be flipping
hamburgers but we're not.
We are doing something that's really
beyond all of us and I say to them,
you know you have to realize that
this music was here long before us
and it'll be here long
after we're gone.
We will never measure
up to this music.
But it's in the trying to
measure up that we become artists.
And the moment that we understand
those parameters and we try
to measure up not only
do we become artists
but hopefully we will
become servants.
So that we are really the conduits.
So that this music
can get communicated
because these composers
don't write music
to demonstrate their
skill at music theory.
They write for, to help us
understand that we were made
to be better than what we
may have thought we were.
So all of that attitude comes out
in the kinds of words you choose
and the way that you treat people.
You know I make it a habit to
learn the names of the members
of the orchestra before my
first rehearsal so I can,
I don't call them by their
label, or by their function.
I call them by their name.
And when you do that it says
I value you as a human being.
I have had on more than one
occasion someone in the orchestra,
I'm not going to say the orchestra
but someone recently came to me
and knocked on my dressing room door
and said you know we always love it,
making music when you're here.
She says but this week
everyone seems to be remark,
because I was there for
two weeks, a long period.
And she said everyone
seems to be talking
about how kind you are to us.
And I tried to blow it off, you
know oh, I'm just a nice guy.
She says no, no, no
you don't understand.
It makes us treat each
other differently.
So that's the job of leadership
is to help usher people
and to become better human beings.
We want our audience to walk
away better human beings
and we want our players to
walk away better human beings.
And if we put ourselves in front
of that, it will never happen.
And so I think first and foremost,
it's a really walk
the talk as it were.
Live the life of a person
who honors other people.
It doesn't mean I'm not their boss.
No one in my orchestra is mistaken
about that but they also know
that I love them dearly as human
beings and I love their families
and I pray for them
on a regular basis.
That kind of stuff, I mean you
don't have to pray for them,
but you know what I mean.
That kind of, that level of
care for them I think has
to be demonstrated first so that my
assistants and our staff they sort
of get the cue from me as to how
we're all going to treat each other
because their boss treats them
in such a way that they compelled
to treat other people that way.
So it's a, I'm happy to say
like in Omaha for example,
it's a great team of people.
And we want nothing but
the best for each other.
I had a young man send me a letter
once, he had seen me conduct
and he wanted to, he wanted some
advice on how to have a career.
And he said in his e-mail
to me that his dream was
to become the next renowned black
conductor, you know, on the globe.
And it just, I was so ticked off.
You know? And I just sat on
the e-mail for a few days
and I didn't answer and then
finally one day I just sat
down and started typing.
And I said okay, if I can give you
any advice here's my first piece
of advice.
Don't ever say that again.
You can dream it, you can desire it,
but don't ever say it out loud again
because you're going to
give people the impression
that this is all about you.
Those people who are in your
audience are real people
with real challenges and real dreams
and real hopes and real obstacles
and the whole reason that they come
to you is so that you can equip them
to leave the room better
than the way they came in.
And guess what?
The players in your orchestra
are the exact same people.
And your job is to equip them
to be better human beings
when you leave you than
when they came to you.
And duh, duh, duh, duh, duh
and to his credit he wrote back
and said you know no one has ever
spoken to me like that before.
No one has ever said, mentioned
the word servant and leadership
in the same sentence ever before.
So yes, I think that's, it's, I said
to him one night I thought of one
of my best friends who's a lawyer.
Actually he's now sort
of a lobbyist.
He, we are sort of
accountability buddies, you know?
We're both successful, both love our
families and our children and duh,
duh, dah, dah but we're
both proud of each other
but we're not impressed
with each other.
You know? So you have
to have partners,
you have to have friends like that.
I said to him the other day, and he
just turned 65 and I just turned 60
and your head goes through all kinds
of junk, you know, in the process.
And I feel great!
I mean I exercise, I play
golf, duh, duh, dah, dah,
but there's still stuff
that messes with your head.
So I said Jeff, I don't want
to be the smart guy anymore.
I don't want to be the
guy handing out advice.
I want to be dumb again.
You know? But anyway.
>> Nick Brown: Well, I'm sure
that gentleman appreciated your
giving him the lesson because.
>> Thomas Wilkins: I think he did.
I hope he did.
>> Nick Brown: Because I'm sure
he realizes that you're someone
who is not going to
share insights lightly
and that can have a
significant positive impact
on his own trajectory.
So that kind of opens a
question about mentorship.
What, do you get involved
in mentoring your assistants
or other musicians in the
orchestras or do you kind
of just do it more informally?
>> Thomas Wilkins: It's
almost, well it's both.
Because we have a fellow at our,
in Omaha, who's now actually,
we have recently promoted him to
being on staff as a conductor.
Excuse me.
And part of the part of my
agreement with him and them was
that he would have to study with
me during the course of the time
that he's there and
now it's just he meets
with me and he brings questions.
Often they are conductorial
questions but sometimes
in fact I just got a text
from him a couple days ago
because he had an audition
somewhere and he took the time
to learn the major players'
names in the orchestra.
And he talked about how
well they responded to that.
You know. So it's all
kinds of advice.
And players come sometimes for, they
want a lesson or they want to talk
about how to exist in this business.
Or you know, how to learn
a, I have people you know
to this day I will still, I
have colleagues that I will call
and say you know I'm thinking about
this starting this movement in four,
and then Leonard Slackhen [assumed]
is one that I always call or e-mail
and say I'm thinking about
doing this, is it crazy?
He says you know no, no, no,
that's the way I'd do it
too or something like that.
So I think not to get hyper biblical
on you but I think every person,
every person needs a Paul, a
Timothy and a Barnabus in your life,
you know, you just sort of
need, you need someone to teach,
someone to learn from,
and then someone
who thinks you're not all that hot.
You know? So.
But so when the opportunity
presents itself I never,
I try never to shy away from it.
Nick Brown: Great.
Are there any sort of areas
in the standard repertoire
or contemporary repertoire that you
haven't delved into as much as you'd
like to and what are they and
when do you plan to get to them?
>> Thomas Wilkins: That's
the cool part I think is
that there's always stuff
you haven't done yet.
And I've always been a big
American music proponent.
And so I've spent a lot of
time doing American music.
I would say I haven't spent enough
time with French repertoire.
And sometimes it's because if
I look at my season and realize
that the orchestra doesn't
have enough of something on it,
I will often invite someone who,
for whom that's their expertise,
because you want someone who's
going to bring something to it
that you won't bring to it
just by having learned it.
So sometimes that keeps me
from getting the repertoire.
But no, I, there's
nothing in particular
that I think I want
to get to except that.
I want to get sort of making
music outside the box more often.
I want to, I want hip
hop brought to the stage.
You know I live in the land
of Saddle Creek Records,
so the whole Indie Rock
thing is still going strong
and I didn't even know it until my
nephew had to tell me, you know.
But I just love, and
that's part of the fun
that I have the Hollywood Bowl is
that we can do I mean we literally
did Sacrifical Dance from the Right
of Spring to open the
show and then John Legend
and Stevie Wonder were
the next things on stage.
I mean, I love that.
And to have the opportunity to
do more of that kind of stuff
and that's kind of the
fun part of my career.
That means the fun for me is that
the fun thing about my career is
that no two weeks are ever the same.
I could be doing you know
Shastakovich one night
and then you know Pink Martini the
next night Ben Folds the next night
and Mozart the next night and a
children's concert the next night
so no, it's, I don't know, maybe
it's something that keeps me excited
about it is that nothing's
ever the same.
>> Nick Brown: On those programs
where juxtapose different genres,
what kind of feedback do
you get from the folks
who might have just come for
Stevie and then heard Right
of Spring for the first time?
>> Thomas Wilkins: Well look
at the Hollywood Bowl the audience
understands that the night is going
to be like that and they
expect it to be like that
and they are always open
to all kinds of things.
But I think you know Duke Ellingson
there's only two kinds of music,
good music and bad music.
I think if because I talk to
all of our audiences if I'm sort
of the thread for them that
connects one piece to the next,
and I can be professorial at one
moment or I can be a comedian.
Or a story teller.
Whatever it feels like, whatever
seems to be necessary at the time
and it sort of helps people receive
whatever it is that we're doing.
And so it sort of mitigates
some of their angst I think.
But I for the most part I
think people are excited.
And we haven't, we sort
of haven't had any issues
where people are you
know, storming the steel.
What I'll tell you though
it was the coolest thing
that happened was the first thing
out of Stevie Wonder's mouth was
oh man that's too risky killed.
So you know I have a friend who
is, James Carter, who you may know,
he's a jazz saxophone player,
one of the most compelling musicians
I've ever been on stage with.
He, we in Detroit were part
of a commission of concerto
for saxophones, of Roberto Sierra,
and one moment he's playing tenor
sax the next he's playing soprano.
The orchestra's a classical
orchestra that he persuades
to become a jazz orchestra
then they persuade him
to become a classic
saxophonist, I mean it's really,
and that's my perception.
But it's a really cool piece.
But when we did it in Omaha,
we did it with [inaudible] four
for obvious reasons
because no one had heard
of Roberto Sierra's concerto
for saxophones, right?
So we did a talk back afterwards.
And the, on stage, and so there's
all these jazzards who came
to see James Carter because
they were like James Carter,
Omaha Symphony, what's that about?
You know. So now they see James
Carter and they come up on stage
for the talk back afterwards
and so one of them said so James
and he was, you know a little grin
on his face, what was it like being
on a concert that also had
[foreign name] four symphony on it?
And James said, man I was as
stoked about hearing [inaudible]
as I was about playing my piece!
He goes so many people go to the
parade and all they do is wait
for the Miss America float.
I want to see the whole parade!
I love that statement!
You know, right, it's,
music is music, come on man!
You know?
>> Nick Brown: So how do
we invite people to be open
to changing their preconceptions
about genres
or classical concert etiquette
or entering a new space,
picking up a new recording,
checking out a new radio station?
>> Thomas Wilkins: I
think it starts with us.
I alluded to this earlier today in
another conversation that I think
as American artists, because
as American classical artists,
because we operate in a western,
primarily a western European
tradition, that we are afraid
that if we do anything that doesn't
look like something [foreign name]
or [foreign name] or Brams
[assumed] would approve,
people aren't going
to take us seriously.
When in reality, you know I did a
program in at the Hollywood Bowl
where we invited over
the Moulin Rouge dancers.
And so I did a classical
music first half of composers
who probably hung out
at the Moulin Rouge.
You know? Because they probably did.
You know? They weren't
stuck in some cave somewhere
where you know just writing.
My point is that we
don't have to apologize
for being an American orchestra.
We don't have to apologize for
being American and we don't have
to apologize for being an orchestra.
And an orchestra by its very nature
is one of the most diverse ensembles
or versatile ensembles rather in
existence because we can become,
we can become a chamber
orchestra, we can become a quintet,
we can become an octet, we
can become anything out of
that large thing, contraption
called the orchestra.
And so we should run towards
our versatility and not away
from our versatility because
we can be different things
for different people.
If we take ourselves more
seriously than we take our art
and by our art I mean all
of this stuff, you know.
If you listen to Niama
[assumed] John Coltrain
and you think that's not
as poignant as any symphony
of Beethoven you are
out of your mind.
If you listen to Miles
Davis you think,
basically it was a trumpet player
who missed notes, you are nuts!
And so we as artists have to be
the voice for that versatility.
But we think if we play in,
and we, and this generation
of musicians doesn't think that way
by any stretch, which is really cool
because they're playing in
rock and roll bars where some
of them are even playing
rock and roll.
You know, a colleague Joshua
Roman is a great example.
He just played Divorsia
[assumed] with me in Omaha
because my soloist got, hurt
his hand, he was a pianist.
And Joshua had just been there doing
Erin J Kernist [assumed] congerital
[assumed] which involves a pic,
I mean it's jazz and all kinds
of stuff, on another series.
And so and he got snowed in, I
mean he basically couldn't get back
to New York so we had him
stay and do the Divorsia.
But he's a great example of
someone who has removed the labels
from music and this is not to say
that there should not be nights
where you hear a Beethoven, a Mozart
and Haydn or Brams and Shuvert
or a Moller on a program.
This is not to suggest that
at all, it's just to say
that in the process let me see
how much I can move you along
to try something else.
Because it's very possible that
you're going to like this, too.
And part of it too is
also a matter of trust.
I had a Russian pianist
say to me once,
how come American orchestras have so
much trouble with the word groove?
And I said how come a Russian
pianist is asking me that question?
You know? How weird is that that
you're asking me why my orchestra
has a trouble with the constant,
Beethoven knew what a groove was.
You listen to the movement
of Beethoven's seven,
you tell me that's not a
groove for crying out loud?
He wouldn't have used that word
but he understood the sensation
and if we can make those kinds
of connections with people,
you know I think we are better off.
You know I grew up with guys,
I was the only classical music
guy in my group of friends.
You know I mean the Wooden Brothers
and Billy Drummen, those guys,
we'd get together on weekends and
I'm playing Tchaikovsky for them
because we had records in
those and that's how we geeked
out on weekends, we
would sit around,
we sat around and listened to music.
They're playing Green Dolphin
Street for me and you know Four
and More and all this stuff.
We're just sharing,
that's all, you know?
I just, in fact just recently I said
one of them that had it not been
for those experiences, maybe I
wouldn't be the kind of conductor
that I am that can one
moment can do Moller
and the next moment can
do you know Stevie Wonder.
But.
>> Nick Brown: Neat.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Yes.
>> Nick Brown: So with the community
engagement you've discussed,
there are lots of ways for the
audience and the musicians to kind
of stay engaged with the
institution of the orchestra.
Outside of the concert experience.
What do you think are the ways
of engaging with each other
that lend the experience to growth?
So like is that social media?
Is that attending the talk balks?
Is that just seeing people out in
your community at the grocery store?
>> Thomas Wilkins: And by growth
you mean growth in numbers or growth
in humanity or growth
all of the above?
>> Nick Brown: I think the
humanity portion especially
or developing a more nuance
appreciation for the institution
and that culture that
you're being part of.
>> Thomas Wilkins:
What we have said is
that if you mention the world music
in Omaha we want your first thought
to be the Omaha Symphony.
What I've said often as an example
of to your point is if I get
in a taxi cab, often if I get in
a car, and I'm not being picked
up by the orchestra's driver, and
they say what are you doing in town?
I say I'm here to conduct the blank
blank blank but I'll say the letters
of the orchestra not the word
orchestra because I want to know,
do they know what I
mean when I say NSO
or you know LPO or whatever it is.
And if they go what's that?
I go rut roh.
You know? And I said
however, if I get in a car
and say do you go to concerts?
And the driver says no, he says
I don't really care for it,
but my goodness did they
turn my 11 year old around.
Then in my mind the
orchestra's doing its job,
it's proved its quote
on quote relevancy.
I had a cab driver in
Omaha, I got in the cab,
and he had classical music on.
And I was going to the airport.
And so I just said so do you
always play classical music?
He goes oh yes, it just relaxes me,
I just that he says well
sometimes it'll be jazz
but most often it's classical music.
I said huh.
And I said do you ever
go to concerts?
And at this point I see him looking
at me in the mirror, his eyes,
he kept you know on the road,
in the rear view mirror.
And then finally he goes,
hey you are the Maestro!
And does he go to concerts?
No he doesn't go to concerts.
But somehow we have entered
his life in a way that he feels
that this is something
he wants to be a part of.
So it's important to be seen in
the grocery store or Home Depot
which is my two, Lowe's, you know
my favorite places to hang out.
And you do, you know I know they're
all anecdotal, but they still count
because they're still
people's stories
and they are sharing
those stories with you.
You know I, standing in the
checkout line at Wal-Mart,
my God the cashier's tatted up
like crazy, you know his is weird,
not weird but it wasn't
my hair that's for sure.
So I had already decided
who this person was, right?
Wrong. Bad thing to do.
Sure enough I get up to the
counter and the dude said,
ma that Right of Spring
performance was really.
>> Nick Brown: What!
[ Laughter ]
Thomas Wilkins: And
here's the thing.
To your earlier point about
growth and even growth in numbers
and making people feel
comfortable in the concert hall,
if we don't have diversity, if
you don't let people be diverse,
you've got to call
it something else.
So if I'm going to judge the
guy who is tatted up who comes
in the concert hall, not in
a suit, then shame on me.
He deserves to hear this
music, too, you know?
So that was a great thing.
Or going through the security line
at the airport, the guy looked
at my driver's license and said
have a good flight Maestro.
>> Nick Brown: In Omaha or in?
>> Thomas Wilkins: In Omaha!
>> Nick Brown: That's cool.
>> Thomas Wilkins: So people are
always doing that kind of thing
which tells me and you know, I'm
involved in so many different kinds
of things that have
nothing to do with music,
the boards that I have
served on or the groups
that I have volunteered for, or the
places that I've given speeches.
I gave the commencement speech
at an elementary school in Omaha.
It was the most fun, you know?
And when you do those kinds of
things, either myself or our staff
of conductors or musicians
playing in various places,
the orchestra ends up having an
imprint all across the community
in the rarest and sometimes
the most secluded of corners.
And it has nothing to do with
those people ultimately coming
to the Holland Preforming
Arts Center for a concert.
It has everything to do with us
giving away this gift of sound.
You know, a friend of mine who's
a visual artists said it's,
he says, how did he put it?
He says outreach is about us
coming to you is like outreach
and you coming to us
is about marketing.
But us coming together,
that's about community.
And so that's, you know you can
be a lot different things to a lot
of different people and everyone is
served and everyone is made better.
>> Nick Brown: So I think to
wrap this up I'd like to hear
from you how that ethos about
community can be instilled
in more conductors
and more musicians.
I know we've touched upon this a
little bit but it's not something
that you're taught in music school.
It's not something that you're
taught by all your private teachers,
whether it's a conducting
teacher or an instrument.
Who filled that role for you?
>> Thomas Wilkins: In a lot
of instances, by not growing
up in a house with a father,
I had to become a sponge.
Why those things became important
to me I can't answer that,
that was just, I feel that, again
without getting hyper religious,
I do feel that this God's call
in my life, this is the thing
that I'm supposed to be doing.
And so there, for me there's a
certain responsibility right off the
bat, and part of that
responsibility means that there has
to be a certain humility because
I didn't create this talent in me.
I didn't create the ability
to be a good public speaker.
I didn't, you know.
A friend of mine said that
all I did was I was obedient
when I was given a gift.
That I didn't you know throw it away
or that's the only thing
I can take the credit
for was that I was obedient.
Again one of those friends who
don't think you're all that special.
But I think, by being
a sponge it meant
that my ears were always
open you know,
I used to journal at some point.
And I knew that I wanted, it
helps when you have role models
and sometimes those role models
don't know they're your role models.
But they were almost always
older men who were good fathers
and good husbands and you
know, you know I said you know
that the best thing I can do for my
children is to love their mother.
And you know, one guy said to me,
he says you know I'll always
know what kind of man you are
by the smile on your wife's face.
He didn't I'll know what kind
of husband you are he said
I'd know what kind of,
I'll know what kind of man you are.
We are good at being boys.
We can boys until we're
50, you know?
But it takes somebody
special to come along
to teach us how to be men.
And I think in the process of
learning how to become a man,
or if you know if were
a woman a woman,
basically what I'm saying is
a grown up, a real grown up.
You have to always be aware
of what you don't know.
And so there have been, there have
just been people in my church,
sometimes there have been
people in our, in business,
people in the music business,
but there's always been someone
who may have said something
or did something and made me go oh,
I've got to write that
down and keep that.
And then I'm a ponderer.
So that was for me that was what did
it was just being willing to listen
and to learn something
and from anybody.
You know? Anybody can
teach you anything.
I have a mantra of the last few
years that says every day I want
to love something, learn something
and leave something behind.
And Wynton Marsalis said that he
was saying it to a group of kids,
he said that you know, your biggest
competitor is not the other person
in the room.
Your biggest competitor
is your ignorance.
So if you get up every day
and decide to do better
with your biggest competitor, then
every day you'll win something.
You know? And I think
maybe that's, that was,
you know I had a friend
who's dad was a salesman,
a very successful salesman.
So he turned me on, you know
those like, all of those sort
of like Robert Schuller, move
ahead with possibility of thinking,
the guy who invented the
round to it who's Zig Zigler.
You know these are guys that
business guys are reading.
I'm reading those as a young
undergrad thinking there has
to be a route to you know
to whatever success is.
And growing up in a housing
project poor, is a great motivator.
And I will tell this one story
of myself if you don't mind.
>> Nick Brown: Please, yes.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Because I still
to this day tell it to my teacher
at New England Conservatory,
who by the way when he came
to my first Boston Symphony
concert pulled me aside
and gave me some instructions.
>> Nick Brown: Oh who was this?
>> Thomas Wilkins: Richard Pitman.
>> Nick Brown: Oh yes.
Oh he's.
>> Thomas Wilkins: He says mind
if I tell you make a couple.
Sure! You know?
But so here I was I
wanted to be a conductor
since I was eight years old.
And I had all these opportunities
through you know high school I
was a student conductor of a band,
and my band director let
me conduct every day.
And if he was going to be absent, he
would just have them hire to someone
to take roll and I
would be completely,
and to all these unbelievable
opportunities
in college every year
in undergraduate school.
So I took two years off and I
don't have perfect pitch, you know,
so I took an audition at at
NEC, New England Conservatory.
There were three spots open.
There were 28 people
auditioning for those three spots.
And so the first part of the day
you had to conduct the orchestra.
Well, I'm so charming.
I mean I had been, I'm
comfortable on the podium,
and I had been for a long time.
The orchestra stood up and
applauded at my audition.
I thought, I was feeling
like really good.
And then in the afternoon,
seven of us at a time,
we had to take the
musical skills test.
And his musical skills test was
like okay, here's a G, alright,
now I'm going to play through
this twice, so I'm thinking, I'm,
he's already done with the first
time, I'm thinking okay, G, okay,
so now, so [inaudible] flat,
well the piece is gone!
But the time I figure out
what key we're in, you know?
And so, and then the single line
dictation that was like boom, boop,
boom, boop, stuff, this kind of
stuff, and then the piano record,
I didn't, my mother couldn't
afford piano lessons.
I never, I had like class piano
as an undergraduate, that was it.
So then we had personal
interviews with him.
And the seven of us went to
lunch together and we were,
we're all like shaking our heads
going this ain't happening.
You know? And so I go to lunch and
I have my personal meeting with him
and he goes, you remind me of Pierre
Montour [assumed] and I went whoa,
oh my gosh, he's comparing me
to somebody famous, you know?
He says you, he says I believe
you could get an orchestra
to do anything just because
of your nature on the podium.
You're very charming.
He says, he's, and then he took out
my test, and he held it like this.
He says but this.
This is ridiculous.
And I went bloop.
He said look, you don't want
to be a Charleton [assumed],
you have to have intellectual
integrity and artistic integrity.
And it turned out he was the person
who also demonstrated moral
integrity which was great.
Speaking of role models.
He says I don't know if
I'm going to take you.
But I'll tell you what.
He says if I were to take you
and you're conducting alone,
I would save one of these three
spots for you right now even
without hearing the
last group of seven.
Because the panels
in a group of seven.
He says but I'll tell you what.
If I do take you, you're going
to have to work your butt off.
And if you don't, and here are
the words, I will not hesitate
to kick you out of school.
And those are the words
that changed my life.
Because to have grown up the way I
grew up, to have had that the dream
to the level that I've had it and to
be on the doorstep of the very place
that could make that, turn
that dream into a reality,
and to have someone say mm mm
[phonetic] that changed everything.
By the following year I
was his graduate assistant.
And I am a great source of
pride for him because my,
when my wife first met him she goes,
you made my husband a workaholic.
He goes, he said, yep!
So but he really did, he said you,
this is not how you
become a conductor.
And so he taught me how to work.
And I had to be able to
play any of the Bach corrals
in open score if, in
order to graduate.
I was like every morning,
you know, at a piano.
But it was the greatest anyone
could ever give anyone and that is
to say wishing without working
only leads to disappointment.
>> Nick Brown: Definitely.
Well I think that's a
great moment to end.
And I really appreciate
you taking the time
to share your story with us.
And we hope that this is
the beginning of a very long
and wonderful relationship
with the Library
and we appreciate your being part of
the Shift Festival, and can't wait
to go hear you in concert coming.
>> Thomas Wilkins:
Me too, it's a great.
>> Nick Brown: Thank you
Maestro, appreciate it.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Take care.
>> Nick Brown: Thank you everyone
and feel free to visit us on LOC.gov
to learn more about the
Library's interviews
with leading American musicians.
Have a great one.
[ Silence ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.